en 1907 un phalanstère d'artistes se
retrouve au bateau lavoir à montmartre
autour de picasso
guillaume apollinaire max jacob se
figure de poètes
c'est ce jeune poète qui n'a pas encore
publié mais qui écrit déjà beaucoup que
marie laurencin à leur compagne de
guillaume apollinaire va saisir dans ce
portrait tout à fait étonnant
ans
bon
au même moment tableau picasso travail à
ces demoiselles d'avignon
très influencé par l'art africain que
les jeunes artistes ont pu découvrir
lors d'une exposition à paris et c'est
vers cette inspiration que marie
laurencin va également se tourner pour
peindre ce portrait de marc jacobs qui
fonctionne comme un masque dans lequel
elle saisit toute la tristesse et la
mélancolie presque mysticisme de ce
poète qui finira sa vie dans une
retraite monacale à saint benoît sur
loire où il sera arrêté par les nazis et
finira ses jours à drancy en 1944
[Musique]